I hate intros Kaguya sama I love this
word season 1 episode 1 we kick things
off at the private shoot Sheen Academy
meeting she know me a Kaguya who is the
vice president of the student council
the president she works with is she
Dogon a Miyuki and both are among the
most talented at the school they use all
of this immense talent to try and make
one another fall in love with each other
or confess the other member of the
student council is the oblivious
bystander to this standoff in Fujiwara
chika Kaguya tries to force Shido
Gandhi's confession through movie
tickets but when too many variables come
up they both overheat and lose leaving
the score at 0-0
Kaguya is next ploy is to feign going on
a date with somebody who gave her a love
letter
this almost works at [ __ ] agon against
jealous and tries to stop it things keep
on escalating until Kaguya decides that
she has to go through with it but
thankfully fuji wata steps in to stop
her giving her her first loss in the
show with 0 to 1 round 3 commences with
Kaguya wanting to try shoot a ghani's
lunch she doesn't want to come right out
and say it and eventually he lets Fuji
whatta try it which pisses her off
because now she's a potential rival the
next day Kaguya kicks things up a notch
when she brings an extravagant lunch
hoping to make him beg her for a bike he
thinks she's pitting him so he refuses
and ends up leaving because kaguya was
gaming off some murder revives sushi
water then offers up some of her lunch
which was actually made by Shiva got a
that day and this remedies their
friendship since [ __ ] Akane had to run
away this ends up being a win for a
Kaguya and making it 1 to 1 episode 2
frown for gets underway when cheetah
gotta get some new smartphone both try
to get the other to ask for their
contact information and both end up
losing leaving the score at 1 to 1
around 5 happened soon after when
they're deciding to make a trip together
on the one hand she tagged on a wants to
go to the mountains so that they can
look at the stars together while Kaguya
wants to go to the beach so that she can
win him over with her swimsuit thang
Akua remembers that Fujiwara has a
better body than her so she might win
over she too got out while she to ghana
is afraid of bugs so they both switch
sides in the standoff making it really
complicated fuji wada has to be the
tiebreaker and wants to go to mountain
sunday ruining both of their plans so
it's still 1:1
six-issue Tigana giving relationship
advice to another student he almost says
some harsh things about Kaguya but at
the last second he sees that she's
eavesdropping he makes a nice save
saying how great she is but since it was
all a waste of time it's considered his
loss so it's two to one II episode three
the next day the three look at a
confiscated magazine that says 34% of
people have had their first time by high
school Kaguya misinterprets this as
their first kiss
so Fuji wada has to explain what it
actually meant this turns into a 30
minute explanation of the birds bees and
due to her lack of knowledge Kaguya has
to take the El on this one
later on Kaguya and she too got a plate
20 questions and at first it seems like
a confession to him he knows her too
well though and the answer turns out to
be a dog which she gets correct the next
day Kaguya is walking because of car
issues and ends up having to help a kid
gets at their school she's going to be
late but luckily she got a gives her a
ride on his bike I'd like to think this
is some sort of foreshadowing done by
the author with a euphemism but I can't
prove it so I guess we'll just let that
one go each episode I'm not entirely
sure what happened here but some cat
ears were brought to the school so [ __ ]
Agana and Kaguya end up trying them on
and then both of find each other cute I
don't know even though they both think
that each other are adorable they have
to play it cool and end up getting kind
of creepy the creepiness ends up getting
so intense that Fujiwara actually has to
confiscate the ears so in the end they
all lose next round the three of them
end up playing forbidden work turns out
Fujiwara takes this game a little too
seriously and demolishes both of them so
neither went since they both lost
Tschida Gani and Kaguya have to go
shopping together as part of the wager
there's an unspoken Brownwood Kaguya
gets another win because she began I
sent her a message first to make plans
for their shopping making it three to
two
although these plans end up getting
canceled because of bad weather the
principal throws a party on short notice
and sends bell toys Betsy the French
schools vice-president to test shoot a
Gani to see if he's a worthy president
she continuously insults him but he
doesn't understand French
Kaguya on the other hand does she's not
gonna have anybody talk to her man like
that so she pops off sending her running
back making this a mutual victory four
to three
yep so by Fujiwara in Kaguya help a
fellow student figure out if she wants
to continue dating her boyfriend they
make her realize she does and they end
up doing some charity work together her
boyfriend just so happened to be the boy
that came to see she tagged on a for
advice so the president ends up helping
in charity also everybody knows that
[ __ ] love charity so Kagura is
totally eating this up
this round is considered to be a loss
for Kaguya making it forward of for now
we get the high q-- arc where she tagged
on and tries to improve his volleyball
skills with the help of Fuji whatta
after a week of hard work he gets really
good all so that he could impress Kaguya
on a rainy day Kaguya ends up stabbing
her chauffeurs tires so that she can
share an umbrella with shita got it
they both act like they don't have
umbrellas which almost causes some
problems but that bougie wada saves the
day again making the round a win-win 5
to 5 episode 6 we learn a little bit
more about the student councils fourth
member that is rarely seen the treasurer
ishigami you ishigami is actually
planning on quitting the student council
but he's kind of holding everything
together he's quitting because he fears
for his life he gets the vibe that
Kaguya wants to kill him so he's trying
to keep his distance of course this is
unlikely and he's probably just being
paranoid so the president convinces him
to trust them a little bit more which
sounds good on paper until she actually
threatens his life to keep him in the
student council but anyways on to the
next round Kaguya plants a book with
questions for who she wanted to find and
memorize all of the questions to answer
properly while we were in schita Gani
ants the saying that he likes her he
sniffs out the trap and dodges it
successfully but then Fujiwara goes
off-script when she finds questions
online
chitta ganas answers make him lose but
Kaguya is too embarrassed to show what
the questions actually meant so he
doesn't know about the loss but it still
is 65 Kayne gets another win later on
when her maid hayasaka does her nails
for her and this gets the attention if
she had a Ghana giving her a quick dub 7
- 5 e episode 7 cheer to Ghana goes on a
la streak when he tries to give some
more relationship advice on holding
hands penny over complicates it a bit
saying that you need to get a job to
hold hands which makes perfect sense so
Kaguya and Fuji wada have to correct his
advice
giving him the l85 he breaks the streak
soon after when pooja wada and kavya
both tried to get him to join their
clubs they both fight over him and he's
loving the attention but at the end of
it all he has a part-time job so he
doesn't join either make him get 8 to 6
bujji wada finds a weakness of kaga who
laughs hysterically at any windows and
uses this to torture her for the rest of
the episode episode 8 it's the start of
a new day and we meet the little sister
of the president she tagged on a cake
Gaggia plans to win her over and
befriend her to get close to the sheet
agonic family as a whole
she's already best friends with Fujiwara
that Persis seems like it could be a
problem but then it ends up being an
opportunity for all of them to hang out
so it works out she tagged on he takes
another quick when when he scores higher
on their exams making the score 8 to 7
she got me is on the verge of being held
back so Kaguya uses someone for the docs
methods to help him study while doing
this we learned that case she got me is
kind of a reject and people tend to stay
away from him so he's kind of hoping he
gets held back to avoid them jagiya
stands up for him to get some girls who
were making fun of him and makes him
feel better it's a nice moment that
doesn't last because he didn't deliver
on the scores that she was expecting so
he gets chewed out anyways episode 9
everyone is stranded because of a
typhoon and shitty gun he doesn't have a
ride home God you could just offer him a
ride but that's too forward and
eventually he has to ride home on his
bike while out in the storm Kaguya gets
sick so she to Ghani along with the
others play a game of memory to see who
gets to go check on her Fuji water
really wants to go check on her so she's
conniving and cheating throughout the
entire game she ends up getting caught
so she'd have gone a wins and gets his
wish to go see her GOG ia's sickness has
left her basically drunk so hayasaka
throw she Tigana a nice layup and gets
them some alone time
Gaga suddenly pulls shita Gani into bed
and naturally the next step is for them
to go to sleep sometimes you give a guy
a way up and he just bobbles that [ __ ]
until everybody cringes when Kaka
finally wakes up she sees shitty Ghani
there and attacks him forcing him to
leave episode 10 the two are at odds
with one another because cog iya thinks
she got a might have done something
while they were sleeping then on the
other hand she Tigana is mad that she
blimey hen so things finally boil over
when they both argue about who gets to
eat a slice of cake from the principal
I'm gonna go ahead and assume that this
is a metaphor for a slice of each other
I want you to have to take no I want you
to have the cake I want you to like me
no I want you to like me just eat it
brews you wat it comes in to stop that
for fighting and eats the cake leaving
them both as losers if this is still
going with the cake metaphor that means
this is an eventual threesome and I
support they both want to make amends
with the other and eventually do so
having things go back to normal
ah summer break is coming up everybody
is thinking about their trip to the
mountains that they planned but no one
wants to bring it up plans end up
changing to go to the summer festival
instead the only problem is that Fuji
whatta can't go so she is the only loser
he episode 11 Gaga has a new dilemma
when she wants to follow she to Ghani on
Twitter but can't work up the courage to
send a request since his profile is
private nothing really happens with that
so we jump over to Fuji whatta who gets
back from her trip to Egypt and we get a
random scene of grown men thinking that
she's some sort of ramen enthusiast
[ __ ] Agana and Kanye are thinking
about each other over break butter to
pancita texts so they go to the student
council office in hopes of running into
one another they just miss each other
and it's super emotional and then we
learn after the credits that Katya isn't
gonna be able to go to the festival to
watch the fireworks because her dad had
summoned her which isn't a big deal they
just have to reschedule but we learned
that kaki his father never showed her
affection or praise growing up she's
more of a decorative piece and just does
as she's told he episode well Fujiwara
had cancels her other plans so that she
could go to the summer festival with
everybody else at the last second Katya
gets the news again that she isn't
allowed to go in response to this
hayasaka offers to pretend to be her
while she breaks the rules and goes out
to the festival she tries getting there
as fast as she can but ends up being
late and misses the fireworks
she to Ghani manages to find her and the
four of them rush to another show that
was delayed they make it just in time to
see the fireworks from their taxi this
turns out to be a huge waste of cab fare
because Kaguya was staring gasps she to
Ghani the entire time the two of them
are too embarrassed to talk about what
happened that night and when kaga tries
to thank him for finding her he
misinterprets and takes it as an insult
waiting to the last victory of the
season bringing the score to nine to
seven I'm gonna be doing the next season
you can find that little app side
whenever I'm finished with a or you can
check out all of the Kaguya sama love is
war recaps in this playlist here you can
also find the links in the description
below and the only thing I hear more
than intros is out roads
you